on sait jamais avec vous quelle est la
part de vérité quelle est la part de
chacun de ces pourris du texas a monté
cette fois alors cette fois je n'ai pas
de dossiers mais je des cadeaux non non
et des canons pour tous
alors allez-y alors fabriquée à deux
reprises vidéo pour cette dernière c'est
manu fabrice merci alors j'ai des bons
cadeaux pour les faisais un cadeau pour
moi un génial associer la boucle de
ceinture elle est magnifique
alors merci et la tenue de compte tu vas
l'année j'ai un cadeau pour tout le
monde va aller où c'est bien merci
fabrice j'ai tout petits chevaux ça vous
permettra de penser à moi pendant l'été
faire mais pourquoi le cheval à cheval
j'ai appris un truc vous voyez s'il ya
un endroit où je m'énerve jamais ch
vannes bat jamais mal à les garder parce
qu'au fond convaincre plus que
contraindre ou c'est ça la clé à cheval
alors évidemment après ça marche si le
cheval est un peu intelligent quoi c'est
que si je suis pas arrivé à convaincre
plus que contre un avec certains d'entre
vous c'est ça le problème est donc mois
après que vous disiez que ce soit un
danger si vous voulez j'ai voulu dire
franchement je m'en fous complètement
en fait pas plus que les compliments ne
me
ne me touche finalement plus que ça
c'est sympa et je vous remercie
finalement ce que vous pensez de moi
c'est peut-être la grande particularité
je m'en fous dire que moi je suis venu
ici parce qu'on m'a invité et la parole
que je porterai pas la mienne on me
demandait de débats très bien je fais ce
que je sais faire je débats et c'est
précisément ce que vous ne savez pas
faire c'est ça qui est dommage c'est que
c'est à l'époque d'emballage et non mais
c'est un peu vrai parce que quand vous
arrivez en disant que je suis à danger
le quai sinon c'est pas du débat c'est à
ces deux là nathalie